roche fait ce geste trop c'est
incroyable comment allez vous petit
aparté j'ai vu vous retour sur le thread
horreur la l'intro hyper content vous a
traumatisé je suis désolé je pensais
vous rendre service mais en fait je vous
ai infligé une plaie alors voilà je
profite de cette intro pour y mettre un
petit pansement vous en faites pas on va
refaire d un trou de 14 minutes y'a pas
de problème
en parlant d'un trop nous sommes
actuellement dans une intro aujourd'hui
nous allons parler aux oies semeta les
vidéos de squeeze 2021 cha cha cha cha
aujourd'hui m'a parlé d'un truc qui me
révolte depuis tant d'années qui aimait
premier degré les télétubbies sans avoir
peur qui levait la main vous vous
désabonner ça sort du ballet j'ai
regardé une fois les télétubbies quand
j'étais petit je m'en souviens encore
mektoub a traumatisé l'ambiance du truc
la gueule qu'ils ont leurs mouvements
bizarres le bébé soleil le rire de bas
bon blague à part je comprends que ça
ait séduit beaucoup d'enfants mais je
faisais pas partie de ces enfants est
derrière un autre dessin animé comme ça
où j'ai jamais compris lui je crois me
faisait encore plus bas dès que les
télétubbies c'était angela anaconda ça
vous dit un truc ou pas je crois que ça
a moins marché que les télétubbies en
vrai en france mais je l'avais vu
passer ce truc là ça m'avait mis mal
bref aujourd'hui je vous ai préparé une
petite sélection de quatre shows pour
enfants que je trouve terrifiant et
glauque
vous n'êtes pas obligé d'être d'accord
avec moi mais franchement j'ai des trucs
à raconter sur ces quatre shows c'est
parti on va commencer avec le plus soft
les fans d'animé quand je vous dis
adaptation live et shon vous gervais je
me souviens à l'époque il y avait une
adaptation de dbz justement live exion
ball evolution
[Musique]
moi j'avoue j'ai du mal et je crois pas
qu'ils se soient systématiquement parce
que l'adaptation est mauvaise je crois
juste que c'est trop bouleversant dette
amoureux de ce personnage depuis des
années et d'un coup qu'il devienne ce
gars dans la vraie vie dans mon cas la
dernière que j'ai vu c'était
l'adaptation netflix d'ailleurs de death
note qui est un chef-d'oeuvre à côté de
ce que je vais vous montrer
connaissez-vous le dessin animé pierre
lapin si vous avez grandi dans les
années 90 ça vous dit sûrement quelque
chose c'est good vibes et la mignotte et
des animaux versus des petites histoires
à droite à gauche avec une petite sauce
de morale on adore ça quand on est
enfant mais ils sont allés trop loin
j'ai donc enquêté et j'ai vu qu'il y
avait eu un film live et shon de pierre
lapin aux les petits animaux mignons qui
danse en cercle
rien du tout on dirait qu'ils célèbrent
la fin de l'humanité et après les avoir
anéanti
ça c'est libre à la sensibilité de
chacun mais moi ça m'a toujours mis mal
à l'aise et mature fait grincer des
dents de faire des créatures mi humain
mi animal je trouve ça bizarre
regardez là par exemple c'est des bras
et des mains d'humains qui pioche dans
la nourriture et sur plans d'après
entend en fait ils ont tous une tête
d'animal mais ça c'est le plus soft
là je vais vous parler d'un vrai truc
j'ai découvert qui est terrible vous
connaissez tous monsieur patate célèbre
personnage du film toy story il est
attachant il est charismatique il est
sympa rigolo on adore toy story 1 est
sorti en 1995 sachez qu'en 1998 les
enfants ont eu le droit à une série
américaine qui s'appelait mister pauthe
et aux aides chaud et dont évidemment
monsieur patate était le personnage
principal en bois dans la série monsieur
patate il va essayer avec ses potes
cuistot de monter une émission de télé
sauf qu'ils leur arrivent plein de
mésaventure pourquoi pas en vrai j'ai
envie de voir la série commence à être
diffusé le 12 septembre 98 et le 16
février 99c ciao on est sur 5 mois
d'existence c'est très rapide pour un
personnage comme monsieur patate et ben
non ça n'a pas du tout marché du coup
les producteurs ils ont décidé d'en
faire un film un film sur pourquoi le
chose s'est arrêtée mais pas du point de
vue de l'équipe qui a travaillé dessus
et cetera pas du tout du point de vue de
monsieur patate c'est hyper meta comme
idée je trouve l'idée bonne en vrai le
film suit les pas trop honnêtement j'en
rajoute pas je vous assure que c'est de
loin le truc le plus bizarre destiné à
des enfants qui ait jamais été créée ne
vous en faites pas je vais vous résumer
ce film en quelques minutes
l'intrigué du film commence sur un
programmateur télé qui annonce à
monsieur patate l'annulation de son
émission télé au je suis machiavélique
je crée ce geste pour que vous le
compreniez bien n'est ce pas monsieur
patate est alors dévastée il remet toute
sa vie en question et là il a une vision
de fou
une cuisinière apparaît et lui fait
réaliser qu'il doit s'accrocher parce
que sa raison de vivre
c'est de faire son émission avec ses
amis monsieur patate apprend la triste
nouvelle à son équipe et l'un d'entre
eux qui apparemment est une part de kish
pas très fraîche n'accepte pas la
situation et décide de voyager dans un
monde parallèle où le show ne serait pas
annulée c'est clairement un bon moyen de
résoudre ces problèmes
allez dans une dimension où le problème
n'a pas eu lieu alors qu'il ne se doute
de rien monsieur patate et son pote
jambon qui est très mignon j'ai beaucoup
d'empathie pour ce genre dont je sais
pas pourquoi partant votre trip
parallèlement la part de quiches et son
acolyte faut pas prendre du recul sur
tout ce que je dis là il tourne dans un
univers parallèle où juste les voix des
personnages sont inversés et où tout le
monde a une barbichette ça les gars
c'est une blague qui me fait rire
premier degré les barbichettes les font
flipper ça me fait flipper aussi perso
c'est ch ob du coup ils se cassent sauf
qu'ils arrivent dans un nouveau monde
parallèle dans lequel monsieur patate
est un monstre géant et pourquoi pas
pourquoi par parallèlement monsieur
patate et son pote le jambon ils
atterrissent dans l'espace ça arrive
j'en ai vu de trois comme ça sur une
aire d'autoroute atterri dans l'espace
et c'est là que le jambon un flashback
de la fois où il s'est fait kidnapper
par des aliens qui l'ont torturé en lui
faisant écouter de la cornemuse ya 0
vannes dans tout ce que j'ai à dire
d'accord c'est parfaitement ce qui se
passe
ils sont donc en panne dans l'espace
parce que les scénaristes n'ont rien à
sauf que des aliens croiser leur
route et il décide de lancer un petit
google vite comme ça et au cours de ce
google mythe
ils vont jusque là chez monsieur patate
et monsieur jambon sur leurs émissions
qui a été annulé et là me demandez pas
pourquoi mais d'un coup il ya une
interlude musical qui dure comme ça
gratos en plein milieu de l'histoire
c'est infernal regarder ya des saucisses
qui chante et impute un trognon tome qui
fait du métal et des poulets qui danse
bref y'a un petit collectif de persos
qui tentent d'avoir un grammys en plein
milieu des aventures de monsieur poteau
à l'issue de cette interview
d'interminables monsieur patate et son
pote jambon parlent à leur tableau de
bord et j'ai rien compris mais
apparemment ça les fait rentrer sur
terre bilan pour résoudre vos problèmes
dans la vie soit voulait fuyez vous
changer de dimension soit vous parlez à
votre tableau de bord on note tout ça de
retour sur terre monsieur patate à la
révélation dont ils avaient besoin
il comprend que c'est pas parce qu'il
est plus diffusés en télé qu'il ne peut
plus faire de contenu avec ses amis ils
rappellent donc toute son équipe pour
monter un spectacle
sauf qu'au même moment les aliens sont à
deux doigts d'envahir la terre guidé par
une plante fantôme la même plante qu'ils
ont fumé avant d'écrire le scénario
c'est sûr monsieur patate et ça
troubles sont donc en plein spectacle
devant un unique spectateurs ça fait un
peu mal au coeur mais un petit imprévu
les poussent à arrêter spectacle les
aliens sont en train de détruire la
terre voilà mais qui refait surface
la cuisinière du début mon pote elles
existent réellement elle est de retour
et elle botte le cul des aliens à l'aide
de son monstre de compagnie ce truc là
la terre est donc sauvée mais monsieur
patate
il est un peu deg abat son spectacle la
vie des îles a vraiment envie de
retourner en télé parce qu'en télé ça
marchait bien
il retombe donc voir le directeur des
programmes qui a toujours ses mains en
forme machiavélique et au fil de la
discussion il s'avère qu'en fait c'est
un alien que ce qu'elle twist mec
c'est inception et monsieur patate et sa
troupe finissent par réussir à retourner
à la télé et là moi je suis fatigué
rennes vous résumer je frime ça va
fatigué bref merci pixar d'avoir
continué à faire de monsieur patate un
personnage attachant et mignon parce que
c'est épisode là c'est vraiment
le dark side de monsieur patate me fait
peur car ils ont enfin bref à l'issue de
ce film qui habitait monsieur péter
tonna bel et bien jamais réapparu dans
son show à la télévision mais voilà je
lui ai rendu hommage en vous racontant
son petit spin off vous penserez à moi
quand le verra dans le prochain toy
story alors troisième émission dont je
veux vous parler
oh encore des têtes d'animaux sur
des humains arrêtés
williams veeckman est un photographe
d'art renommé dans les années 60 pour
maîtres anciens mettre en scène pour
mettre en scène des chiens dans des
situations de la vie de tous les jours
sympa entre temps nous on s'est fait
désensibiliser de tout ça parce que
voilà on a eu 1 milliard mais faire ça à
l'époque
bien joué les photos de william était
tellement apprécié que dans les années
90 les créateurs de sesame street doucet
les pop est ultra connus que sont
devenus des mêmes vous les connaissez
c'est sûr se sont dit que ce serait une
bonne idée de faire une série live
action de ses photographies en gros le
but de la série c'est d'apprendre
l'alphabet en formant des lettres puis
en illustrant chaque lettre avec des
mots maux cours représente à l'aide de
braque de weimar
au-delà du fait qu'à cinq ans ça
m'aurait fait pas des devoirs un chien
cuisiner comme un humain la série est
trop bizarre déjà je pense à ces pauvres
comédiens là qu'ils voulaient jouer dans
un tarantino et au final ils on est
collé au dos d'un chien qui pue et
doivent faire des trucs à l'aveuglette
leurs mains fourquet l'enfer non mais
regardez moi ça au sérieux les mecs ils
ont cru que c'est un sketch de cyprien
trottier la moitié perruque merde
attendez attendez allez hop je vous ai
offert la lettre v c'est pour moi les
américains ils avaient donc le muppet
show très connus sesame street dont la
mascotte principal et kermit en
tchécoslovaquie
on avait un show équivalente dont la
mascotte principal c'était lui nous
lurel il fait tellement bad et excusez
moi mais les mecs qui ont créé il avait
vraiment juste une housse de couette
quoi dans leur atelier à temps à un
moment on est à deux doigts du
déguisement d'halloween du fantôme la
soul draps c'est super grave son nom
sert à ta fac plh tard puisqu'il veut
littéralement dire la couverture au gros
nez au moins si on est hélas il ya deux
que j'adore c'est qu'à l'époque ratafia
qui a déjà des gens qu'ils trouvent un
peu creepy et le créateur aurait répondu
qu'il a intentionnellement fait creepy
car il était avant-gardiste
quand vous faites un truc là qu'est
n'hésitez pas dit non mais c'est parce
que je suis avant gardiste tu peux pas
comprendre alors à ta fac c'était l'un
des personnages d'une émission télé un
peu comme casimir chez nous pour ceux
qui connaissent
en gros tu as un présentateur tu as des
enfants qui sont invités et puis tu as
des marionnettes comme ça qu'ils
interagissent avec le tout aidé en cela
d'ailleurs tu avais pas coeur à ta fac
tu avais cette main soleil qui est
clairement sous lsd et qui est sûrement
la grand-mère du bébé soleil d'été
tiësto j'ai l'impression que c'est la
vidéo d'introduction d'une secte j'ai
très peu à l'aise justice'' serata fac
qui se fait chier un clairement pendant
l'émission il médite il en train de se
faire un avis sur le film de mister pau
tête au juste ici les mises en scène en
train d'enterrer un gosse j'ai bien
l'impression comment un enfant à
l'époque pouvaient l'adoré et bien
croyez moi il était tellement aimé qu'il
a même eu le droit à son propre clip de
musique dans lequel est dense
je vois la tête du gars de ce la couette
je la vois on ne rigole mais sachez qu
en tchécoslovaquie c'était vraiment un
personnage méga influentes dans le monde
des enfants et petite anecdote mignonne
en 2008 ratafia qu'il est allé devant la
salle dans laquelle il y avait des
élections de miss univers avec une
pancarte
les femmes sont toutes belles il est
parfait j'aimerais que cette vidéo dure
trois heures je prends trop de plaisir
j'adore les trucs destinés aux enfants
mais qui sont creepy et c'est le cas
d'ailleurs la deuxième masse cadeaux
j'aimerais vous parler dans cette vidéo
fofana alors pareil c'était le
personnage principal d'une émission de
télé dans les années 80 au brésil
l'émission ballaro magical lui il a fait
essentiellement des musiques et elles
ont eu un succès de fou alors qu'est ce
qui s'est passé avec lui et ben écoutez
lui il a été victime d'une rumeur méga
gluck
je voulais dit c'est une véritable icône
donc du coup il y avait énormément de
produits dérivés de marche à son effigie
et par miss march
il y avait une poupée qui a fait
scandale à la fin des années 80 il ya
des bruits de couloirs qui disent qu'on
pourrait trouver un couteau à
l'intérieur d'un certain modèle de
poupée de faux fao les parents
évidemment s'inquiètent pour leurs
enfants et ils décident naturellement de
boycotter la poupée c'est un truc qui
est resté dans la mémoire des brésiliens
à tel point qu'en 2016 sauf ao revient à
la mode mais pas en tant que mascotte
mignonne qui fait des sons pour enfants
mais en tant que personnage creepy comme
les tchèques qui comme les jason bref
comme le sont toutes les égéries
d'halloween et en 2020 il ya carrément
des brésiliens qui font une vidéo dans
laquelle ils font un homme boxing de la
fameuse poupée en question pour vérifier
s'il ya bel et bien un couteau dedans ou
pas ils veulent des bugs la rumeur quoi
et pour vous dire à quel point cette
histoire avait fait du bruit à l'époque
la vidéo en question des youtube heures
a fait onze millions de vues c'est
vraiment énorme ya vraiment un intérêt
de fou pour cette légende urbaine je
vous laisse découvrir du coup ce qui se
passe
à décevant tout ce cinéma pour ça pour
l'armature de la poupée très décevant
voilà j'ai adoré cette histoire et je
trouve ça fou qu'un personnages mignons
et culte des années 80 soit devenue une
égérie du monde de l'horreur pour une
rumeur qui date d'il ya 40 ans je trouve
ça incroyable et bien écoutez c'est la
fin de cette vidéo je trouvais ça cool
de vous raconter tout ça et vous est ce
qu'il ya des trucs que vous trouviez
mégalo qui vous faisiez peur que vous
étiez petit on sait pas pourquoi je me
suis l'un pas pourquoi j'avais peur des
télétubbies je me souviens pas pourquoi
j'avais peur de angela anna combat mais
ce que je me souviens c'est que j'avais
peur j'aimerais trop me remettre dans la
tête du mois quand j'étais enfant genre
essayer de comprendre pourquoi j'avais
peur de tel est l émission et pourquoi
un autre n'avait pas du tout peur bref
j'espère que ça vous a plu je tombe sur
des trucs je me gênerai pas pour vous
raconter les trucs que je découvre a
très vite dans une prochaine vidéo et
oui vous êtes fan de lui je sais c'est
normal il un truc
[Musique]